soutenez-vous la manifestation les
policiers s'il vous plaît non hein alors
raquel garrido senora kg il n'était pas
la manifestation en effet un enjeu parce
que je suis en radical désaccord avec ce
qui est portée voilà que recule alors
c'est ça le problème
mais non mais c'est que là il faut faire
preuve d'un petit peu de tolérance
l'abbé coutts et c'est bien aussi dans
la police de comprendre ce rôle est dans
une société libre et qu'il ya des gens
qui ont le droit de pas être d'accord
avec ce que disent les syndicats de
policiers ou certains sont des
représentants mais pas sûr que parce que
parce qu'il y en a qui sont pas d'accord
avec les manifestants d'aujourd'hui
moi je suis du côté de la sécurité je
suis du côté de ceux qui nous protège
sud deux côtés de les citoyennes comme
moi qui a besoin c'est d'un triste et
j'ai que ça correspond pas je ne suis
pas d'accord pour focaliser l'attention
sur certains enjeux que medhat met en
avant les syndicats et pas d'autres
voiliers et coiffe yeux et bas par
exemple la question du suicide chez les
pros mais et les changements du soudan
sont touchés mais ces bons sujets sur
lesquels qui est très important il n'y a
pas plus ce sujet qui est terrible les
deux morts bah si mais sauf que ça
serait bien qu'à la maison les gens
comprennent que il ya plus de morts
d'aujourd'hui celle dans la police par
suicide d'accord c'est bien c'est pour
ça que c'est pour ça que la et les
filles participent pas ou c'est bon ça
on va en parler avec la corogne où il
n'y a pas de terreau 1
et j'ai l'impression d'embêter le
recteur de la caméra c'est un truc de
ouf
non mais oh quand vous entendez des gens
qui disent qu'ils ne ne soutiennent pas
de la manifestation des policiers puis
se met à écouter ça me choque parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous étions quand même
trente cinq mille personnes mais non
renseigné musiciens comprend sa misère
tu n'y étais pas à quelle heure vous
parliez tolérance tout à l'heure oui
mais c'est maintenant par leur art
d'affaires de monde sarko tu dois bien
aussi aux citoyens coraux et de nombreux
chasseurs connu en chine où de nombreux
citoyens sont venus nous soutenir parce
que vous savez les conditions d'exercice
ultra difficile de votre métier vous
savez levitine de nantes de violence ce
sont les policiers on prend des pam et
or les pas payer ce qu'en pareilles à
ceux qui les prennent dans la gueule des
pavés et effectivement quand voilà donc
qui a serré ce cas là et peut aussi en
parler tout à fait donc il y avait là
dessus c'est très bien qu'on soit venu
parce que on a des revendications fortes
il y avait des images fortes en vidéo
qui ont été montrées et il ya un état de
colère et d'agde exaspération profonde
je vous rappelle que la police est quand
même le donne le dernier rempart
républicain de notre institution alors
jean marie bigard vous étiez la
manifestation absolument pas je suis un
ami de la police
j'ai un côté de moi un mec qui est un
ami de vingt ans qu à risquer sa vie
pour la france
il est mon ami et moi c'est que je
dirais aussi la travaillent et
travaillent avec moi donc je pense tout
simplement que moi je globalement je
sais pas quels sont les guerres internes
oui au milieu de deux d'un police ce que
je sais moi simplement c'est que c'est
des mecs qui sont au service de la
nation
je suis à fond avec eux et je suis donc
résolument un ami de la police je trouve
insupportable qu'on puisse ou s'attaquer
à eux qu'ils se fassent caillassé qu'ils
se fassent ou assassinés ils sont au
front il gagne pas beaucoup d'argent et
donc c'est pas très populaire peut-être
d'être avec la police mais moi je suis
tout le mondial est capitaine on recule
crim mais alors que c'est la chose la
malice mais tu te contredis tu te
contredis c'est une partie non j'ai rien
à envier russie je suis un ami de paul
huchon dirais que l'écriture est
pourquoi le dire non mais jean marie
bigard les attendait qu'il ya des façons
défend la police - par exemple chez moi
je défends la police dans l'autre
prétendant commissariat et pour votre
maison mais dans mon dos m'a mis là
cette année pour que le haut
commissariat soit ouvert ce pub chez moi
chez moi si je me fais agresser ou là
des après 17 heures j'ai pas de
commissariats pour aller porter plainte
parce que le commissariat il est fermé
voyez donc je dois qu'elle a
effectivement le déloger c'est l'extrême
droite à l'heure actuelle rappelle
explique moi pourquoi tous les
parlementaires de gauche de droite du
parti communiste jadot étaient présents
et pourquoi les filles étaient pas
présents parce que peut-être qu'ils ont
un problème de compréhension des
principes républicains dans ce pays ces
gens là des problèmes de compréhension
c'était pas le moment de vendre ce
n'était pas le moment auquel je suis dit
que votre problème c'était la justice
mais la police est servie par sa troupe
et nodari nos peaux mates que ça non
mais vous prenez à parle quand je vous
la donne
isabelle morini bosc elle en a moins moi
je suis un peu surprise raquel parce que
tu tout ce que tu n'y va dans le sens de
la police et 2010 fallait pas y aller
nous y serons en ce moment ils les flics
ils sont là pour protéger aurait
d'autres passaient leur temps à essayer
de se protéger
donc et un vice de forme absolument
profond et là on en est intel stable
maintenant que oui je pense que
profondément et vous soutenir absolument
sans réserve sans réserve à laquelle
vous prendrez pas le cas je vous la
donnerais ma chérie n'est pas ce qu'il
ya laurent nguyen qui est là qui étaient
contre cette manifestation des policiers
vous êtes responsable syndical cette
série suit crs je suis peu c'est la
première fois que je fais un plateau
télé ben j'ai jamais eu un jour de
détachement comme les délégués syndicaux
professionnel sait rien à voir avec la
main
64 et déjà non je suis pas contre la
manifestation des policiers chinois je
suis contre l'instrumentalisation des
souffrances des policiers s'étaient pas
de manifestation de policiers c'était
une manifestation organisée par
certaines organisations syndicales
policières la majorité tout géré présent
mais c'est si vous parlez de la majorité
cependant non non non non c'était les
organisations syndicales
jusque là on sait ce que vous comprenez
tous les français je vous dis pour eux
ça ne rien dire ça c'est une unité
vraiment mais non ça fait les syndicats
ces vigies police pourquoi ils
comprennent pas parce qu'on passe leur
temps à leur raconter des conneries à
faire de la polémique et on va pas
déclinantes et qui eux nous des gens
comme vous qui êtes là tout de suite à
démarrer mais quand vous dites par
exemple pourquoi là et les filles
n'étaient pas là mais oui j'ai pas mal
mais oui mais moi j'étais passé les élus
sur pan de la république laissez-moi
réponse vous plaît vous voulez quoi
voulez faire une liste de tous les
citoyens qui est absent mais il y en
avait plein de citoyens présents
d'affairé ni ses citoyens et les
policiers est riche et les français
qu'on va le mettre sur le passeport
sanitaire n'était pas la manifestation
de soutien des policiers mais et je vous
posais une question de se marrer vous
avez participé aux manifestations de
soutien aux enseignants vous avez
participé aux manifestations de soutien
aux agriculteurs sous une barbe et les
réseaux médias les paris policier j'y
vais j'ai passé trente six à mon ami 36
ans comme ça je vous le dis j'ai risqué
ma peau pour la paix mais ça je vous dis
pas le contraire c'est pas la peine de
faire vos états de service monsieur
pommard p mais à ce moment là
maxwell et soutient nos soignants fois
les soutiens noa noa mais parlons de la
police le sujet c'est soutenez vous vous
de l'améliorer stationnés pour lui
demander des comptes aux politiques qui
étaient absents à ce moment-là demandant
des comptes aux politiques qui étaient
absents qui ont pas soutenu les
enseignants ils sont allés partout s'il
vous plaît gilbert dess vous dites
nombre aussi je ne soutiens pas la
manifestation je sois prêt à faire cette
tête là je soutiens la police bien
entendu mais cette manifestation elle et
je suis d'accord avec monsieur elle est
détournée de son sens qu'il est née une
manifestation qui n'était pas une marche
de soutien au policier mort moi je
pensais que c'était celui là j'aurais
dit oui bien sûr c'était père il m'a
sauvé pour des revendications syndicales
c'était devant l'assemblée nos mains
celles représentant les secteurs et sur
lequel souvenirs
ça m'a choqué que des policiers quand un
de vous
de neutralité de réserve soit devant
l'assemblée nationale pour faire
pression pour que des lois soient
modifiées de c'est pour défendre les
policiers moi en tant que voilà je vous
le dis en tant que citoyen pour moi un
policier il est exemplaire il a un
devoir de neutralité ne va pas devant
l'assemblée pour réclamer que la loi
change of mood sens total choqué a dit
en tant que je voyais je suis absolument
en désaccord avec gilles verdez je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à un
police machine qui est intolérable sur
insupportable moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
de savoir si c'était tel souci dans les
policiers on a vu aussi une femme sont
ici l'autre jour qui est venu sur le
plateau ils ont la peur au ventre quand
ils vont travailler comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure très justement isabelle morini
bosc
ils sont insultés ils sont caillassés il
arrive il y a quelqu'un il ya quelqu'un
qui dit un truc très vrai et li shi les
flics entre déjà s'engueule on se
demande comment on peut y avoir du
dialogue et citoyens c'est sa place
cyril cyril geste je rappelle juste 35
policiers traquent c'est un policier par
jour de blessés aujourd'hui là on est
sur un plateau il ya là qui sont blessés
dix mille policiers par des est-ce que
les syndicats c'est pas le rôle de
monter au créneau et de mettre la
pression gouvernement oui oui mais oui à
quelles excuses à ceux qui en parlent
bien ce qu'il est moi je voulais les
syndicats sont là pour nous dire ce qui
me pose problème c'est que vous il ya eu
beaucoup il ya eu beaucoup de paroles et
il ya eu beaucoup d'intimidations à
produire les listes de ceux qui étaient
là ce qui était pas là à demander des
comptes à ceux qui n'étaient pas là vous
vous venez de le faire avec ma maman de
garrido que je ne cautionne pas ce que
les fils opposition toujours contre la
police ont lieu ces jours-ci auquel tu
le sais aucun moment parlé on parle des
choses vraiment important d'eau pourquoi
on a cependant cette violence dans notre
pays
qu'est-ce qui va pas dans notre pays
qu'est ce qui fait qu'en 40 ans notre
pays il a sombré comme ça alors que
c'est quoi les vraies préoccupations des
français
qu'est-ce qui va pas il ya 10 millions
de personnes qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté de pauvreté dans notre pays on
a cinquante policiers par an quasiment
qui se suicide
quand on rentre dans la police
aujourd'hui quand on est rentré dans la
police ya dix ans on a plus de risque de
mort par suicide de sa propre main que
de toutes les autres causes réuni que ce
soit les accidents le csc pour sa guerre
et cette manif en amènera les pas et les
os 5 les os majoritaire ne font et c'est
pour ça que sonia sursaut il ya surtout
professionnel vous êtes des pouces avec
des professionnels ont fait sur et du
ministère je ne t'ai jamais des héros et
sienna autres rôles et professionnel il
pèse quand même 99%
oui collègues parce que oui oui la
police et vote aux élections
professionnelles à plus de 15 ans a
simplement oui parce que sinon combien
représentait ils votent pas pour vous
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'avancement mais si c'est la vérité
j'ai fait 36 ans dans la maison je
reconnais que la vérité excusez moi en
tout cas important et on va y venir
c'est tout de même un souci au niveau de
la justice pénale il s'agit pas attiré
attendait julien cégep a tiré sur
institutions justice oui mais j'ai pas
déjà non je ne fais que des magistrats
qui bosse de manière exemplaire
simplement que la justice un manque de
moyens comme nous simplement il ya des
choses tout de même vous avez une
circulaire du garde des sceaux mais 2020
qui explique la régulation carcéral
exactement que si vous êtes enfermé aux
condamnés tous deux entre 0 et 6 mois de
prison
vous ne faites pas votre peine alors est
ce que ne pas faire de peine et une
paire et un rating est ce que c'est le
bon schéma est aujourd'hui on arrive à
un stade c'est quoi votre seuil où il ya
une crise de l'eau traitée d'état la
solution c'est en fonction des délits
qui sont commis pas bête ou en prison
gratuit mais qui est une réponse
immédiate et l'exécution des peines
lasserre 6% des peines de prison sont
pas fait prier dans le pays complètement
d'accord vous avez par exemple quelqu'un
l'a récemment qui a été condamnéà
collègues de crétins qui meurent en 29
jours d'itt et d avertir le mec si
verizon il n'a jamais trempé prenez donc
vous savez que monsieur que monsieur
qu'il ya un an personne de
l'administration qui a volé dans les
caisses destinées aux enquêtes dans s'en
fout il est petit on sent les aimez mais
qu'elle met 15 mais quel rapport avec
leur mail a pris un an de prison ferme
il sait que monsieur claude guéant il
est temps mais quel rapport
c'est la politique parlant des policiers
les problèmes des policiers des guerres
on s'en fout
non mais franchement j'aimerais qu'on a
sur la manifestation des points si je
passais mieux s'est passé parce que de
décevoir les gens qui nous écoutent en
coulisses tout à l'heure à peu près tout
le monde
mais oui était d'accord mais il fallait
qu'on protège dents longues et que vous
méritez d'être félicités pour leur
travail globalement après ce sont des
petites colères interne qui n'intéresse
strictement neuf millions de français
qui vit sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est
magnifique
qu'est ce qui a manqué qui a marqué un
milliard de personnes qui crèvent de
faim dans le monde mais ce n'est pas les
marques au sein de la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui crée la
violence qu est ce qui crée la
délinquance qu'est ce qui crée la colère
sociale
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des gens
d'assez la justice et la faim dans le
monde
voilà ans d'accord mais c'est que ça n'a
juste rien à voir a su que des bottes
mais un 26 ans s'immole à dieu les
violences les violences ils ont reçu
bien léché et non mais c'est le sens que
tôt rien est fait autour lewin fait le
tour des oui des gens qui soutiennent de
ce qui s'est fait aujourd'hui pour
soutenir le policier c'est tout et où le
rsa sans fil guerre on s'en fout
enfin scénique par les deux syndicats
est positif la colère des policiers elle
est parfaitement légitime il exerce un
métier de plus en plus difficile plus en
plus dangereux c'est à respecter à la
fois par une partie des français qui les
respectent pas à cause de leur uniforme
pas respectés par l'état qui selon moi
ne les paye pas assez compte tenu de la
difficulté d'un métier dont chef c'est
normal qu'ils manifestent et j'espère
qu'on trouvera des solutions lorsque
encore casser les éducateurs
soutenez-vous les manifs et oui à soi
c'est bien sûr c'est pas la bonne
question moi pour cent ainsi j'ai la
bonne question c'est la question posée
les jours pour ça c'est beaucoup non
six couples à vrai dire parce qu'elles
gagnent tel matraquage et une telle
présentation comme ça marche et on
craque elle se tenait plaît ça marche
mais les amp est nuancée moi je suis
pour la police je suis pour une police
républicaine les soirées alors laissons
les diffuser pour une police
républicaine que ça ne me plaît pas
qu'ils aient les coulisses de police max
yeux voilà je n'aime pas quand eric
zemmour méfia villiers avec des
syndicats des sram brad pitt à la
boucherie mélenchon comme si c'étaient
mes lancers c'est la cérémonie plus
qu'ils savaient pas du bien au chaud